[Music]
hey everyone welcome to other
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
suffer a Snape aka the half-blood Prince
when Harry first takes Slughorn's potion
class he is without a textbook he's then
instructed by Slughorn to go and find a
spare textbook in the classroom little
did he know at the time but the textbook
that Harry found was huge for him in
this particular school year
Harry sought to become one of Slughorn's
favorites and to become selected by
Slughorn and in order to do so he needed
to excel in his class the copy of
advanced potion making that he found
allowed him to do just that after
opening the textbook Harry immediately
noticed his writing inside this book is
a property of the half-blood Prince
Harry uses the book for quite some time
as for each and every one of Slughorn's
lessons the book provided easier and
clearer instructions that he could
follow the book was like having cheat
codes to all of the potions lessons but
inside the book was not just advice on
how to make potions
there were also spells written inside
spells that Harry hadn't seen before in
my most recent video I discussed
Sectumsempra and why I felt that it
wasn't an unforgivable curse if you
haven't seen that video yet then go and
check it out after this Sectumsempra is
perhaps the most notable of the spells
that Severus Snape created and it was
written right in how his copy of advance
of potion making Harry who isn't
entirely sure what the spell does yet
actually uses the spell on Malfoy which
was a bit of a mistake anyway
Sectumsempra isn't the only spell that
Snape has created and in this video I'm
going to be diving into each of the
spells that Severus Snape is responsible
for producing before we get started it's
worth mentioning that spell creation can
be highly dangerous and has proven to be
extremely difficult only witches and
wizards with extreme patience and an
astounding understanding of magic have
been able to successfully invent new
spells Snape by any standard has been
extremely successful first let's get the
one that you know already out of the
Sectumsempra we first see Sectumsempra
in the films when harry uses it on
Malfoy in half-blood Prince the name
Sectumsempra comes from the combination
of two Latin words sectors which means
having been cut and semper which means
always Sectumsempra is a vicious dark
curse that acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts upon its target often after being
struck the target will lay there
motionless as they lose blood it is
somewhat of a specialty of Snape's and
his featured in his textbook for
advanced potion making after Harry
discovers Sectumsempra he first uses it
on Malfoy and then even tries to use it
on Snape himself to which Snape responds
you dare use my own spells against me
Potter Harry was of course unsuccessful
at using the spell on Snape as he knows
it better than anyone the following
excerpt describes the effects of the
spell blood spurted from Malfoy his face
and chest as though he had been slashed
with an invisible sword he staggered
backward and collapsed onto the
waterlogged floor with a great splash
his wand falling from his limp right
hand slipping and staggering Harry got
to his feet and punched toward Malfoy
whose face was now shining scarlet his
white hands scrambling at his
blood-soaked chest during the battle of
the seven potters Snape attempted to use
the curse to sever the hand of a fellow
Death Eater but due to a slip he
accidentally cut off George Weasley's
left ear instead the following exchange
between Remus and Hermione explains this
he lost an ear said Lupin lawston said
Hermione
Snape's work replied Lupin George
Wesley's ear was gone for good as cursed
wounds are generally unable to be healed
and the counter-curse which I'll explain
next was unknown to the order of the
Phoenix this brings us to Snape snake
spell the counter-curse for Sectumsempra
vulnera sanentur bull naira comes from
the Latin vuln s which means wound and
sanentur comes from the Latin sanera
means to heal vulnera sanentur
is the only known defense or treatment
for Sectumsempra and is used
the blood flow healed the wound and
removed the effects of the curse for
vulnera sanentur to be used most
efficiently it has been expressed that
the incantation has to be repeated three
times the first time the Incan tation is
uttered it eases the flow of blood the
second time it's uttered it begins to
heal the wounds and the third time it's
uttered the wounds will be fully healed
in order to prevent scarring it's also
necessary to use dittany which is a
magical plant used in potion making it's
a powerful and restorative healing herb
that makes fresh skin grow over a wound
the use of vulnera sanentur is described
in the following excerpt he knelt over
Malfoy drew his wand and traced it over
the deep wounds harry's curse had made
muttering an incantation the sounded
almost like song the flow of blood
seemed to ease Snape wiped the residue
from Malfoy's face and repeated his
spell now the wounds seemed to be
knitting the next spell on this list is
lava corpus lleva corpus comes from the
Latin laverre which means lift and
corpus which means body this means that
the spell could be literally translated
to light body it's unknown when Snape
created the spell but we know that the
marauders knew about it most of the
spells that Snape created were actually
created with his enemies the marauders
in mind
according to sirius black he knew more
curses when he arrived at school than
half the kids in seventh year the spell
became popularized in the time Snape
attended the school but no one knew that
it was him who actually created it Remus
Lupin has expressed that during his time
at school students could barely move
about without being hoisted up in the
air by their ankle when Snape created
the spell his intention was that it be
cast non-verbally however it can also be
produced when the incantation is at it
allowed the following excerpt describes
of a corpus in action pointing his wand
at nothing in particular
he gave it an upward flick and said lava
corpus inside his head there was a flash
of light ron was dangling upside down in
midair as though an invisible hook had
hoisted him up by the
the forth spell in this list is the
counter spell to live a corpus libera
corpus the name libera corpus comes from
the Latin words Liber err which means
free and corpus which we saw earlier
that means body
it basically means free the body there
seems to be a trend with most of Snape
spells where he creates a counter curse
and this is no exception
James Potter infamously uses names only
the corpus spell against him and then
releases him using nebera corpus on
Lily's instruction this is expressed in
the following excerpt he jerked his wand
upwards Snape fell into a crumpled heap
on the ground the fifth spell in this
list is the muffler Otto charm the
muffler Otto charm is less sinister than
Snape's other spells like Sectumsempra
and more just annoying it's used to fill
the ears of any person in the caster's
vicinity with an unidentifiable buzzing
sound this allows for conversation to
occur without being overheard it was
created sometime between 1971 and 1978
and in the 1988 to 1989 school year that
wick actually teaches this charm to his
students after Harry and Hermione learn
of this charm they both get good use out
of it the following excerpt describes
the use of the charm
perhaps most useful of all muff leotta a
spell that filled the ears of anyone
nearby with an unidentifiable buzzing so
that lengthy conversations could be held
in class without being overheard the
sixth spell in this list is Lang lock
lang lock like the muffler Otto charm
isn't so sinister but can come in handy
on occasion the word lang is the root
forked tongue or language and lock is
lock the spell effectively locks one's
ability to speak it does this by causing
the tongue of the victim to a fix to the
roof of their mouth it was created to
prevent people from speaking out loud
but actually has a practical use in a
jewel setting as it could prevent an
opposing witch or wizard from uttering
an incantation the spell is said to work
on both humans and spirits
Harry notably uses the spell on peeves
the poltergeist as expressed in the
following excerpt
Harry aimed his wand at peeves and said
line lock peeves clutched at his throat
gulped then swooped from the room making
obscene gestures but unable to speak
owing to the fact that his tongue had
just glued itself to the roof of his
mouth he also used the spell on Auguste
Filch twice during the school year to
which he received a general applause the
seventh and final spell on this list is
the toenail growing hex which is a
rather innocent hex it causes the
victims toenails to grow at an
alarmingly fast rate the following
excerpt describes Harry's discovery of
the hex Harry had already attempted a
few of the princes self-invented spells
there had been a hex that caused
toenails to grow alarmingly fast in 1996
Harry who wasn't afraid to try out the
spells from his advanced potion making
book actually used it on vincent crabbe
it apparently produced very entertaining
results the spell creation is no easy
task
so it's impressive that Severus Snape in
his formative years no less was able to
produce so many some of the spells that
he created are widely used and
recognized and in many cases people just
don't know that he was responsible for
creating them Snape was only 38 years
old and he died but in the time that he
was alive he showed so much promise and
so much expertise in so many different
areas I think that if Snape were to have
survived the Wizarding war he could have
been one of the most powerful wizards
ever if he had lived a longer fuller
life then he could have nearly been in
contention power wise with the likes of
Dumbledore and Voldemort not quite there
but almost and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please remember
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel as always leave your video
suggestions down below until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]